un anuncio impactante desde cuatro zonas
de ucrania controladas por rusia a
partir del viernes y a lo largo de 5
días las regiones separatistas de donges
lugansk así como gerson y zap orilla
están preparadas para celebrar un
referéndum para decidir si formar parte
de rusia o no
hemos trazado el camino para unirnos a
rusia y no hay vuelta atrás sobre la
base de los resultados del referendo
apelaré personalmente el presidente de
la federación rusa vladimir putin para
que los apruebe legalmente lo antes
posible el referéndum o un plan
rotundamente rechazado por los líderes
occidentales reunidos en nueva york para
la asamblea general de la onu presidente
de francia de manuel bacón dijo que
cualquier referendo próximo es ilegal y
no será reconocido la uis y azteca de la
guerra el 120 sesión en rusia declaró la
guerra invadió esta región lanzó bombas
mató gente y obligó a otros a huir y
ahora rusia dice que va a organizar un
referendo en esta misma región sería
gracioso si no fuera tan trágico es
cínico y obviamente no será reconocido
por la comunidad
en un vídeo en zapala con minuta
nacional el anuncio de la consulta se
produce después de que moscú sufriera
varias derrotas sobre el terreno este
mes en ucrania un movimiento que según
el asesor de seguridad nacional de eeuu
jake sullivan coloca a rusia en una
posición de debilidad
en how in way teniendo en cuenta lo
transparente y directo que es este
esfuerzo político ruso anunciando un
referéndum dentro de tres días es el
acto de un país que ha sufrido reveses
militarmente y diplomáticamente y esos
reveses están impulsando a ucrania para
lograr sus objetivos
además de las pérdidas de moscú en el
campo de batalla el presidente de rusia
está cada vez más aislado en el
escenario mundial la semana pasada los
líderes de china e india- dos estados
aliados de rusia le comunicaron
directamente a vladimir putin sus
temores sobre la guerra